Marvel announced that there will be a
Black Panther sequel yeah very cool yeah
yeah Marvel CEO said it was a difficult
decision but ultimately we decided to
make another billion dollars I thought
it over there was a chart in the room
another billion dollars and oth yeah I
don't know what do we do let's get
Chinese food in here and work this out
I've got some big celebrity news Beyonce
announced that she is going on tour this
summer with jay-z Beyonce jay-z Beyonce
jay-z yeah it's the I'm keeping an eye
on him tour
[Applause]
she never leaves the stage FoxNews is
about to debut its new tagline did you
know that they're gonna have a new
tagline yeah
instead of fair and balanced they're
going with the new tagline thanks for
watching mr. president have another
cheeseburger that's a long tagline
speaking of the Trump administration the
Trump administration is about to unveil
its Middle East peace plan yeah yes it
involves giving everyone guns
[Applause]
Conan's got an edge that was a guy
saying that that's the weird thing in an
interview education secretary Betsy
DeVos says she's not unqualified for the
job just misunderstood
she said yeah the actual word she used
was misunderstood innate it
Costco's in the news Costco was selling
a doomsday food kit that can feed a
typical family for a year
doomsday food kit yeah walmart sells the
same kit but it only feeds a typical
Walmart family for six days
get out another one oh that's it that's
her Tim's take it you gotta be kidding
me
a nightclub in Miami has lost its
business license after her woman brought
a horse onto the dance floor
she brought a horse on the dance floor
yeah in the nightclubs defense the
horses ID looked real now
whose story was like you're an organ
donor right I acted out the horse I'm a
grown man speaking of men the hell was
that
you laughed completely when no one else
was laughing don't get me wrong I loved
it but I just just that I loved it that
was fantastic
thank you and please keep that company
just love that the man who gained
notoriety for having sex with a dolphin
I'm gonna say that again the man who
gained notoriety for having sex with a
dolphin says he thought the shape of
water was good if a little long yeah he
said yeah which is also what the golf
had said about him
right Oh
[Music]
34 I swear God that's funny
what's it did you say something no
nothing at all I thought you said it was
gay
such a child I'm such a child I don't
know I don't know your new medication is
not working or it's really worth
you